The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN GUTTAG: Hello, everybody.
Well, here we are
at the last lecture.
We're going to finish talking
about statistical sins
and then do a little
bit of a wrap-up.
Let's look at a hot topic--
global fiction-- or global
warming, fact or fiction.
You've done a
problem set related
to temperatures in the US.
Here is a plot
generally accepted
of the change in temperatures
on the planet between 1880
and 2014.
Now, if we look at this plot,
we could see this commits one
of the statistical sins I
complained about on Monday,
that look where it's
starting the y-axis, way down
here at 55.
And you remember, I told you to
beware of charts for the y-axis
doesn't start at 0.
So maybe the people
who are trying
to claim about global
warming are just deceiving us
with this trick of the axis.
So here's what happens
when you put it at 0.
And as you can see--
or barely see-- this axis
runs from 0 up to 110
as the average temperature.
And as you can
see quite clearly,
it's hardly changed at all.
So what's the deal here?
Well, which is a more accurate
presentation of the facts?
Which conveys the
accurate impression?
Let's look at another
example, maybe
a little less controversial
than climate change--
fever and flu.
It's generally accepted
that when you get the flu
you might run a fever.
So here is someone
who had the flu.
And this is plotting their fever
from the beginning to its peak.
And it does appear, if we
were to fit a curve to this,
it would look pretty
much like that.
On the other hand, if we assume
that somebody's temperature
could range between
0 and 200, we
can see that, in fact, your
temperature doesn't move
at all when you get the flu.
So the moral is
pretty clear, I think.
Even though on Monday I talked
about being suspicious when
people start the
y-axis too far from 0,
you should truncate
it to eliminate
totally preposterous values.
No living person
has a temperature
of 0 degrees Fahrenheit.
So again, don't truncate it
just to make something look
like it isn't, but don't
expand it to deceive either.
Let's return to global warming.
This is a chart
that was actually
shown on the floor
of the US Senate
by a senator from Texas,
who I shall not name.
And obviously, the
argument here was
that, well, sure global
warming bounces up and down.
But if we go back, we can
see here, the date is 19--
can we see it?
I can see it.
Maybe 1986, I think.
You can see that
the argument here
is, in fact, if you fit a trend
line to this, as he's done,
it hasn't changed at all.
And so even though we've had
a lot of carbon emissions
during this period,
maybe global warming
is not actually happening.
This is in contradiction to
the trend I showed before.
Well, what's going on here?
This is a very common way that
people use statistics poorly.
They confuse
fluctuations with trends.
What we see in any
theories of data--
time series, or other series--
you always have fluctuations.
And that's not to be
confused with the trend.
And in particular, what you
need to think about when you're
looking at a
phenomenon is choose
an interval consistent with the
thing that's being considered.
So we believe that
climate change
is something that happens over
very long periods of time.
And it's a little bit
silly to look at it
on a short period of time.
Some of you may
remember two years ago,
we had a very cold winter here.
And there were people
who were saying, well,
that shows we don't
have global warming.
Well, you can't really conclude
anything about climate change
looking at a year, or
probably not even looking
at 10 years or 20 years.
It's a very slow phenomenon.
On the other hand,
if you're looking
at the change in
somebody's heart rate,
seeing if they have
a heart condition,
you probably don't want to look
at it over a 10-year period.
So you have to decide
what you're doing
and find an interval that lets
you look at the trends rather
than the fluctuations.
Any rate, maybe even if we're
having global warming, at least
the Arctic ice isn't
melting, though apparently,
I read in the paper this morning
they found a huge crack in it.
So this was reported
in the Financial Post
on April 15, 2013.
You can read it yourself.
But the basic
import of it is they
took the period from April
14, 1989 to April 15, 2013
and said, look,
it's not changing.
In fact, the amount of
arctic ice is unchanged.
Well, what's the financial--
not the financial-- what's
the statistical sin being
committed here?
If we look at this data,
this is an anomaly chart.
I think you saw one of these
in one of the problems sets,
where you fix
something at 0 and then
you show fluctuations
relative to that.
So here, it's the Arctic
ice relative to a point.
And what we see here is
that if you go and choose
the right date--
say this one in 1989--
and you come over here and you
choose the right date in 2013--
say this one-- you can then
draw a line and say, oh, look,
it hasn't changed.
This is something
people frequently do,
is they take a
whole set of data,
and they find two points that
are consistent with something
they believe.
And they draw a line
between those two points,
fit a curve to those two points,
and draw some conclusion.
This is what we
call cherry picking,
I guess from the
notion that when
you go to pick cherries you only
want to pick the right ones,
leave the others to ripen
for a bit on the tree.
It's really bad.
And it's something
that, unfortunately,
the scientific literature
is replete with,
where people look
at a lot of data,
and they pick the points that
match what they want to prove.
And so as you can see, while
the trend is quite clear,
you could prove almost anything
you wanted by selecting
two points very carefully.
I could also show
that it's crashing
much faster than people think it
is by picking these two points.
If I wanted to argue
that it's catastrophic,
I'd pick those two points
and say, look at that,
it's disappearing at
an incredible rate.
So you can lie in either
direction with this data
by careful cherry picking.
As a service to you, I know
the holidays are coming
and many of you have not bought
presents for your parents,
so here's a modest
gift suggestion,
that the family that shoots
together something or other.
Well, all right, so we can
ask, is this a good gift?
Well, probably.
We can look at this statistic.
It's not dangerous at least.
We see that 99.8% of
the firearms in the US
will not be used to
commit a violent crime.
So guns apparently are not
actually dangerous, or at least
not in the hands of criminals.
Well, let's look at this.
How many privately owned
firearms are there in the US?
And anyone want to guess
who hasn't looked ahead?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: 400 million.
JOHN GUTTAG: 400 million.
340 million people
and 400 million guns
is the guess, more
than one per person.
You certainly are the
right order of magnitude.
I think it's about 300 million,
but it's hard to count them.
Maybe this doesn't
count water pistols.
So if you assume there
are 300 million firearms
and 0.2% of them
are used to commit
a violent crime
in every year, we
see that how many
crimes is that?
600,000.
So in fact, it's
not necessarily very
meaningful to say
that most of them
are not used to commit a crime.
Well, let's look
at another place
where we look at a statistic.
Probably most of you don't even
remember the scary swine flu
epidemic.
This was a big headline.
And people got so
scared of the swine flu
they were doing things
like closing schools
to try limit the
spread of the flu.
New York City closed some
schools because of it,
for example.
So is this a scary statistic?
Well, maybe, but here's
an interesting statistic.
How many deaths per year
are from the seasonal flu
in the US--
the ones we try and
prevent with a flu shot?
36,000.
So what we see is that, it
doesn't make a lot of sense
to panic over 159 in the
light of this number.
So the point here for
both this and the issue
about the firearms is
that context matters.
Yeah, I love this cartoon.
A number without context
is just a number.
And numbers by themselves
don't mean anything.
So to say that there were
159 deaths from the swine flu
is not very meaningful
without some context.
To say that only
0.2% of firearms
are used to commit
a violent crime
is not very meaningful
without context.
Whenever you're
presenting a statistic,
reading about a
statistic, and you just
see a number that
seems comforting
or terrifying, try and put
some context around it.
So a related thing
is relative to what?
Suppose I told you that
skipping lectures increases
your probability of
failing this course by 50%.
Well, you would all feel
great, because you're here.
And you would be laughing at
your friends who are not here,
because figuring that will leave
much better grades for you.
What does this mean, though?
Well, if I told
you that it changed
the probability of failing
from a half to 0.75,
you would be very tempted
to come to lectures.
On the other hand, if I told you
that it changed the probability
from 0.005 to 0.0075, you
might say, the heck with it,
I'd rather go to the gym.
Again this, is an issue.
And this is something that we
see all the time when people
talk about percentage change.
This is particularly prominent
in the pharmaceutical field.
You will read a headline saying
that drug x for arthritis
increases the probability of
a heart attack by 1% or 5%.
Well, what does that mean?
If the probability was already
very low, increasing it by 5%,
it's still very low.
And maybe it's worth it not
to be in pain from arthritis.
So talking in
percentages is, again,
one of these issues of
it doesn't make sense
without the context.
In order to know
what this means,
I need to know what regime
I'm in here in order
to make a intelligent decisions
about whether to attend lecture
or not.
It goes without saying, you have
all made the right decision.
So beware of
percentage change when
you don't know the denominator.
You get a percentage by
dividing by something.
And if you don't know
what you're dividing by,
then the percentage is
itself a meaningless number.
While we're sort of talking
about medical things,
let's look at cancer
clusters to illustrate
another statistical question.
So this is a definition of a
cancer cluster by the CDC--
"a greater-than-expected
number of cancer cases
that occurs in a group of
people in a geographic area
over a period of time."
And the key part
of this definition
is greater-than-expected.
About 1,000 cancer clusters per
year are reported in the US,
mostly to the Centers
for Disease Control,
but in general to
other health agencies.
Upon analysis, almost none
of them pass this test.
So the vast majority,
some years all of them,
are deemed actually not
to be cancer clusters.
So I don't know if-- has
anyone here seen the movie
Erin Brockovich?
Subsequent analysis showed
that was actually not
a cancer cluster.
It's a good movie, but turns
out statistically wrong.
This, by the way, is
not a cancer cluster.
This is a constellation.
So let's look at a
hypothetical example.
By the way, the other
movie about cancer clusters
was the one set
in Massachusetts.
What was the name?
A Civil Action.
Anyone see that?
No.
That was a cancer cluster.
Massachusetts is about
10,000 square miles.
And there are about 36,000
cancer cases per year
reported in Massachusetts.
Those two numbers are accurate.
And the rest of this
is pure fiction.
So let's assume that we had
some ambitious attorney who
partitioned the state into 1,000
regions of 10 square miles each
and looked at the
distribution of cancer cases
in these regions trying to find
cancer clusters that he or she
could file a lawsuit about.
Well, you can do
some arithmetic.
And if there are 36,000
new cancer cases a year
and we have 1,000
regions, that should
say that we should
get about 36 cancer
cases per year and per region.
Well, when the attorney
look at the data,
this mythical
attorney, he discovered
that region number
111 had 143 new cancer
cases over a three-year period.
He compared that to 3
times 36 and said, wow,
that's 32% more than expected.
I've got a lawsuit.
So he went to tell
all these people--
they lived in a cancer cluster.
And the question is,
should they be worried?
Well, another way to look at the
question is, how likely is it
that it was just bad luck?
That's the question
we've always ask when
we do statistical analysis--
is this result meaningful, or
is it just random variation
that you would expect to see?
So I wrote some code to simulate
it to see what happens--
so number of cases,
36,000, number of years, 3.
So all of this is just the
numbers I had on the slide.
We'll do a simulation.
We'll take 100 trials.
And then what I'm going to
do is for t in the range
number of trials, the locations,
the regions, if you will,
I'll initialize each to 0,
1,000 of them, in this case.
And then for i in the
range number of years
times number of cases per year,
so this will be 3 times 36,000.
At random, I will assign the
case to one of these regions.
This is the random.
Nothing to do with cancer
clusters, just at random,
this case gets assigned to
one of the 1,000 regions.
And then I'm going to check if
region number 111 had greater
than or equal to 143, the number
of cases we assumed it had.
If so, we'll increment the
variable num greater by 1,
saying, in this trial of 100,
indeed, it had that many.
And then we'll see how
often that happens.
That will tell us how improbable
it is that region 111 actually
had that many cases.
And then we'll print it.
Does that makes
sense to everyone,
that here I am
doing my simulation
to see whether or not how
probable is it that 111
would have had this many cases?
Any questions?
Let's run it.
So here's the code
we just looked at.
Takes just a second.
That's why I did only 100
trials instead of 1,000.
I know the suspense
is killing you.
It's killing me.
I don't know why
it's taking so long.
We'll finish.
I wish I had the Jeopardy
music or something
to play while we
waited for this.
Anna, can you home some
music or something to keep
people amused?
She will not.
Wow.
So here it is.
The estimated
probability of region 111
having at least 1 case--
at least 143 cases--
easier to read if I
spread this out is 0.01.
So it seems, in fact, that
it's pretty surprising--
unlikely to have
happened at random.
Do you buy it?
Or is there a flaw here?
Getting back to
this whole question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
flawed because first off you
have to look at the population.
That is more important.
JOHN GUTTAG: You
have to look at what?
AUDIENCE: Population as opposed
to like the number of areas,
because when you get past the
Boston area, you'd expect a--
JOHN GUTTAG: Let's assume
that, in fact, instead of
by square miles--
let's assume the
populations were balanced.
AUDIENCE: Then I also
think it's flawed
because I don't think the
importance of block 111
having 143 is important.
I think the importance is just
one area having a higher--
JOHN GUTTAG: Exactly right.
Exactly right.
I'm sorry, I forgot
my candy bag today.
Just means there'll be
more candy for the final.
What we have here is a
variant of cherry picking.
What I have done
in this simulation
is I've looked at 1,000
different regions.
What the attorney did
is, not in a simulation,
is he looked at 1,000
different regions,
found the one with the most
cancer cases, and said,
aha, there are too many here.
And that's not what I
did in my simulation.
My simulation didn't
ask the question,
how likely is it that there
is at least one region
with that many cases.
But it asked the
question, how likely is it
that this specific region
has that many cases.
Now, if the attorney had reason
in advance to be suspicious
of region 111, then
maybe it would have
been OK to just go check that.
But having looked at
1,000 and then cherry
pick the best is not right.
So this is a simulation
that does the right thing.
I've left out the
initialization.
But what you can
see I'm doing here
is I'm looking at the
probability of there
being any region that
has at least 143 cases.
What this is called in the
technical literature, what
the attorney did is multiple
hypothesis checking.
So rather than having a single
hypothesis, that region 111 is
bad, he checked 1,000
different hypotheses,
and then chose the one
that met what he wanted.
Now, there are good
statistical techniques
that exist for dealing with
multiple hypotheses, things
like the Bonferroni correction.
I love to say that name.
But you have to worry about it.
And in fact, if we
go back to the code
and comment out this
one and run this one,
we'll see we get a
very different answer.
The answer we get is--
let's see.
Oh, I see.
All right, let me
just comment this out.
Yeah, this should work, right?
Well, maybe you don't
want to wait for it.
But the answer you'll
get is that it's actually
very probable.
My recollection is it's a
0.6 probability that at least
one region has that many cases.
And that's really
what's going on
with this whole
business of people
reporting cancer clusters.
It's just by accident,
by pure randomness,
some region has
more than its share.
This particular form
of cherry picking
also goes by the name of the
Texas sharpshooter fallacy.
I don't know why people
pick on Texas for this.
But they seem to.
But the notion is, you're
driving down a road in Texas
and you see a barn with a bunch
of bullet holes in the wall
right in the middle of a target.
But what actually happened
was you had a barn.
The farmer just shot some
things at random at the barn,
then got out his paint brush and
painted a target right around
where they happened to land.
And that's what happens when
you cherry pick hypotheses.
What's the bottom line of all
these statistical fallacies?
When drawing inferences from
data, skepticism is merited.
There are,
unfortunately, more ways
to go wrong than to go right.
And you'll read the
literature that tells you
that in the scientific
literature more than half
of the papers were
later shown to be wrong.
You do need to remember that
skepticism and denial are
different.
It's good to be skeptical.
And I love Ambrose Bierce's
description of the difference
here.
If you had never
read Ambrose Bierce,
he's well worth reading.
He wrote something called
The Devil's Dictionary,
among other things, in which
he has his own definition
of a lot of words.
And he went by the
nickname Bitter Bierce.
And if you read The Devil's
Dictionary, you'll see why.
But this, I think, has
a lot of wisdom in it.
Let's, in the remaining few
minutes, wrap up the course.
So what did we cover in 6.0002?
A lot of things.
If you look at the technical,
things were three major units--
optimization problems,
stochastic thinking,
and modeling aspects
of the world.
But there was a big
subtext amongst all of it,
which was this.
There was a reason our problem
sets were not pencil and paper
probability problems,
but all coding.
And that's because
we really want,
as an important
part of the course,
is to make you a
better programmer.
We introduced a few
extra features of Python.
But more importantly,
we emphasized
the use of libraries, because
in the real world when
you're trying to build things,
you rarely start from scratch.
And if you do
start from scratch,
you're probably
making a mistake.
And so we wanted to get you
used to the idea of finding
and using libraries.
So we looked at plotting
libraries and machine
learning libraries
and numeric libraries.
And hopefully, you
got a lot of practice
in that you're a way
better programmer than you
were six weeks ago.
A little more detailed--
the optimization problems,
the probably most important
takeaway is that many
important problems
can be formulated in terms of
an objective function that you
either maximize or minimize
and some set of constraints.
Once you've done
that, there are lots
of toolboxes, lots
of libraries that you
can use to solve the problem.
You wrote some
optimization code yourself.
But most of the time, we
don't solve them ourselves.
We just call a built-in
function that does it.
So the hard part is
not writing the code,
but doing the formulation.
We talked about
different algorithms--
greedy algorithms,
very often useful,
but often don't find
the optimal solution.
So for example, we looked
at k-means clustering.
It was a very efficient
way to find clusters.
But it did not necessarily find
the optimal set of clusters.
We then observed that
many optimization problems
are inherently exponential.
But even so, dynamic
programming often
works and gives us a
really fast solution.
And the notion here is this is
not an approximate solution.
It's not like using
a greedy algorithm.
It gives you an exact solution
and in many circumstances
gives it to you quickly.
And the other thing I
want you to take away
is, outside the context
of dynamic programming,
memoization is a generally
useful technique.
What we've done there is
we've traded time for space.
We compute something, we
save it, and when we need it,
we look it up.
And that's a very common
programming technique.
And we looked at a lot
of different examples
of optimization-- knapsack
problems, several graph
problems, curve fitting,
clustering, logistic
regression.
Those are all
optimization problems,
can all be formulated as
optimization problems.
So it's very powerful
and fits lots of needs.
The next unit--
and, of course, I'm
speaking as if these things
were discrete in time,
but they're not.
We talked about optimization
at the beginning.
And I talk to an
optimization last week.
So these things were sort
of spread out over the term.
We talked about
stochastic thinking.
And the basic notion here is
the world is nondeterministic,
or at least predictably
nondeterministic.
And therefore, we need
to think about things
in terms of probabilities most
of the time, or frequently.
And randomness is a powerful
tool for building computations
that model the world.
If you think the
world is stochastic,
then you need to have
ways to write programs
that are stochastic,
if you're trying
to model the world itself.
The other point we made is
that random computations--
randomness is a
computational technique--
is useful even for
problems that don't appear
to involve any randomness.
So we used it to
find the value of pi.
We showed you can use
it to do integration.
There's nothing
random about the value
of the integral of a function.
Yet, the easiest way to
solve it in a program
is to use randomness.
So randomness is a
very powerful tool.
And there's this whole
area of random algorithms--
research area and
practical area that's
used to solve
non-probabilistic problems.
Modeling the world-- well, we
just talked about part of it.
Models are always inaccurate.
They're providing some
abstraction of reality.
We looked at
deterministic models--
the graph theory models.
There was nothing
nondeterministic
about the graphs we looked at.
And then we spent more
time on statistical models.
We looked at simulation models.
In particular, spent
quite a bit of time
on the Monte Carlo simulation.
We looked at models
based on sampling.
And there-- and also when
we talked about simulation--
I really hope I emphasized
enough the notion
that we need to be
able to characterize
how believable the results are.
It's not good enough
to just run a program
and say, oh, it has an answer.
You need to know whether
to believe the answer.
And the point we made is
it's not a binary question.
It's not yes, it's
right, no, it's wrong.
Typically, what we do is we have
some statement about confidence
intervals and confidence levels.
We used two
variables to describe
how believable the answer is.
And that's an important thing.
And then we looked at tools
we use for doing that.
We looked at the
central limit theorem.
We looked at the empirical rule.
We talked about
different distributions.
And especially, we spent
a fair amount of time
on the normal or
Gaussian distribution.
And then finally, we looked
at statistical models
based upon machine learning.
We looked at
unsupervised learning,
basically just clustering,
looked at two algorithms--
hierarchical and k-means.
And we looked at
supervised learning.
And there, we essentially
focused mostly
on classification.
And we looked at
two ways of doing
that-- k-nearest neighbors
and logistic regression.
Finally, we talked about
presentation of data--
how to build plots,
utility of plots,
and recently, over the last
two lectures, good and bad
practices in presenting
results about data.
So my summary is,
I hope that you
think you've come a long way,
particularly those of you--
how many of you were
here in September when
we started 6.0001?
All right, most of you.
Yeah, this, by the way,
was a very popular ad
for a long time, saying that,
finally women are allowed
to smoke, isn't this great.
And Virginia Slims sponsored
tennis-- the women's tennis
tour to show how good it
was that women were now
able to smoke.
But anyway, I know not everyone
in this class is a woman.
So just for the men
in the room, you too
could have come a long way.
I hope you think
that, if you look back
at how you struggled in
those early problems sets,
I hope you really feel that
you've learned a lot about how
to build programs.
And if you spend enough
time in front of a terminal,
this is what you
get to look like.
What might be next?
I should start by saying,
this is a hard course.
We know that many
of you worked hard.
And the staff and I
really do appreciate it.
You know your return
on investment.
I'd like you to remember
that you can now write
programs to do useful things.
So if you're doing a UROP,
you're sitting in a lab,
and you get a bunch of data from
some experiments, don't just
stare at it.
Sit down and write
some code to plot it
to do something useful with it.
Don't be afraid to write
programs to help you out.
There are some courses
that I think you're now
well-prepared to take.
I've listed the ones I know
best-- the courses in course 6.
6.009 is a sort of introduction
to computer science.
I think many of you
will find that too
easy after taking this course.
But maybe, that's
not a downside.
6.005 is a software
engineering course,
where they'll switch
programming languages on you.
You get to program in Java.
6.006 is a algorithms
course in Python
and I think actually
quite interesting.
And students seem
to like it a lot,
and they learn about algorithms
and implementing them.
And 6.034 is an introduction
to artificial intelligence
also in Python.
And I should have listed
6.036, another introduction
to machine learning in Python.
You should go look for
an interesting UROP.
A lot of students come
out of this course
and go do UROPs,
where they use what
they've learned in this course.
And many of them really have
a very positive experience.
So if you were worried that
you're not ready for a UROP,
you probably are--
a UROP using what's
been done here.
You can minor in
computer science.
This is now available for
the first time this year.
But really, if
you have time, you
should major in
computer science,
because it is really the
best major on campus--
not even close, as
somebody I know would say.
Finally, sometimes
people ask me where
I think computing is headed.
And I'll quote one of my
favorite baseball players.
"It's tough to make predictions,
especially about the future."
And instead of my
predictions, let
me show you the predictions
of some famous people.
So Thomas Watson, who
was the chairman of IBM--
a company you've
probably heard of--
and he said, "I think there is
a world market for maybe five
computers."
This was in response
to, should they
become a computer company,
which they were not at the time.
He was off by a little bit.
A few years later,
there was an article
in Popular Mechanics, which was
saying, computers are amazing.
They're going to
change enormously.
Someday, they may be no
more than 1 and 1/2 tons.
You might get a computer that's
no more than 3,000 pounds--
someday.
So we're still waiting
for that, I guess.
I like this one.
This is, having written
a book recently,
the editor in charge of
books for Prentice Hall.
"I traveled the length and
breadth of this country
and talked with the best people.
And I can assure you that
data processing is a fad that
won't last out the year."
MIT had that
attitude for a while.
For about 35 years, computer
science was in a building
off campus, because they weren't
sure we were here to stay.
Maybe that's not why, but
that's why I interpret it.
Ken Olsen, an MIT graduate--
I should say, a
course 6 graduate--
was the founder and
president and chair
of Digital Equipment
Corporation, which in 1977 was
the second largest computer
manufacturer in the world based
in Maynard, Massachusetts.
None of you have
ever heard of it.
They disappeared.
And this is in part
why, because Ken said,
"there's no reason anyone would
want a computer in their home,"
and totally missed that
part of computation.
Finally, since this is the
end of some famous last words,
Douglas Fairbanks,
Sr., a famous actor--
this is true-- the last
thing he said before he died
was, "never felt better."
Amazing.
This was from the movie
The Mark of Zorro.
Scientists are better.
Luther Burbank, his last words
were, I don't feel so good.
And well, I guess not.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is the last one.
John Sedgwick was a Union
general in the Civil War.
This is a true story.
He was riding behind
the lines and trying
to rally his men
to not hide behind
the stone walls but to stand
up and shoot at the enemy.
And he said, "they couldn't hit
an elephant at this distance."
Moments later, he was
shot in the face and died.
[LAUGHTER]
And I thought this was
an apocryphal story.
But in fact, there's a
plaque at the battlefield
where this happened,
documenting this story.
And apparently, it's quite true.
So with that, I'll
say my last words
for the chorus, which is I
appreciate all your coming.
And I guess you
were the survivors.
So thank you for being here.
[APPLAUSE]